salut tout le monde vous savez ça fait
longtemps que j'ai hésité à refaire un
tour du côté des jeux de combat est la
première raison c'est parce que j'aime
pas ça et ensuite aussi parce bête parce
que parce que j'aime pas ça en fait
c'est déjà une bonne raison alors les
soirées jeux de combat ça un peu disparu
maintenant depuis l'arrivée d'internet
mais rien ne remplacera le charme d'une
soirée en fumée et des manettes qui suez
la transpiration
surtout que les jeux de combat c'est un
peu comme une expérience humaine c'est
un peu un révélateur de la personnalité
de chacun c'est là qu'on découvre les
bons perdants
bon bah j'ai perdu à quel tour où les
mauvais perdants
bon ben j'ai perdu un tenez prenez lui
par exemple un son truc c'est de se
plaindre des gens qui se pâment les
boules de feu assez nul tu fais toujours
pareil mais quand on y pense si c'était
un match de boxe vous pensez que le
boxeur irait faire ça monsieur l'arbitré
c'est nul mais ça fait toujours du point
de droit et d'ailleurs ces soirées c'est
aussi l'occasion pour le maître de
maison de sélectionner de bons jeux de
combat je nous ai fait une petite
sélection pas piquée des hannetons
non sérieusement on voulait jouer à quoi
quand on évoque street fighter on pense
tous spontanément à street fighter 2
parce que street fighter 2 c'est le
pivot de tous les combats d'une manière
générale on peut dire qu'on a plusieurs
générations de jeux de combat et on à
l'avant street fighter l'après street
fighter l'après mortal kombat qui a
emmené la mode de merde à la de tous les
jeux avec des personnages digitaliser et
l'après virtua fighter qui a donné tous
les jeux de combat modernes en 3d type
tekken soulcalibur etc mais vous savez
si on parle de street fighter 2 ça
sous-entend qu'il ya eu un street
fighter un avant sa merci c'est sympa
d'ailleurs pour l'histoire et comme on
peut le voir sur cette image dégueulasse
sur laquelle on voit rien du tout une de
ses versions du jeu de sur arcade se
jouer avec deux gros boutons et avait la
spécificité qu'on sortait des plus gros
coups si on appuyer plus fort sur les
boutons ce système il a été très vite
abandonnée je vous laisse deviner
pourquoi je m'en fous comment tu fais
bon alors concernant le jeu en lui-même
c'était évidemment très naze un déjà
riou et héroux c'est un défaut mais
surtout le problème de ce jeu de combat
cessa mais non watts au complet merde
vous imaginer jouer ça c'est une vraie
borne d'arcade l'argent que vous devez
claqué
1 vous avez perdu tout votre argent en
jouant street fighter non j'ai perdu que
cinq portes et b mais j'adore foot c'est
pas long à vendre sur la maison c'est
vraiment abusé c'est incroyable c'est
limite si la borne te lâcherai pas un
rond à la gueule tellement qu'elles
doivent aller vite les pièces abdou
match que ce jeu soit plus jouer
aujourd'hui ça serait drôle qu'un
blogueur commentateurs de jeu de combat
présente street fighter 1 et on est
parti avec les choeurs dit d'entrée de
sagat tf1 c'était quatre gardes
commentateurs de jeu de combat qui
présentait street fighter ce jeu il est
impossible mais vraiment tu ne peux pas
le finir ce ne serait pas possible tu te
fais défoncer en boucle contre le redis
j'ai essayé mais par contre contre notre
joueur dect à maîtriser la technique des
ados ken bon c'est bon t'as gagné
puisque chaque coup retire 50% de la
barre de vie et évidemment quand je veux
dire maîtrisé en fait je veux dire quand
par hasard tu réussis en sortir une
après avoir sexuellement agressé taborn
pendant plusieurs minutes
en tout cas de dos c'est à ça que
ressemble c'est de la voix off n'est pas
censé avoir entendu ça c'est dingue
quand même en faisant exactement deux
fois de suite la même manip une fois ça
va sortir et une fois non et c'est la
borne qui choisit si elle a envie
quant aux autres personnages et bien
y'en a pas un
voilà ici pas de rinçage d'oeil sur les
puissants puis c'est les arrogants
bichon de chun-li ici tout ce que vous
pourrez admirer ces le torse viril de
vinifie brindacier accary ou ben moi ça
me dérange pas qui a dit ça
bref y'a aucun autre personnage jouable
enfin si juste kent pour le 2ème player
mais en réalité c'est juste une
différence graphique parce que ce sont
exactement les mêmes
et de toute façon ce jeu il sent le
vieux pat est allé fuck le but de jeu de
combat c'est que ce soit équilibrée
ainsi qu'un bon gameplay je veux dire
bon l'histoire les graphismes tout ça
c'est bien mais c'est un peu secondaire
finalement vient si demain on sort en
jeu combat qui soit fun rapide et bien
équilibrée sur pas pitié pour les
croissants belle tout le monde ira jouer
à pas de pitié pour les croissants
après il ya eu d'autres street fighter
un peu nul alors bon je vous parlerai
pas de street fighter the movies guèye
parce que bon finalement il est assez
jouable quand même
c'est très moche le souci de ce jeu
c'est plutôt qu'il a pas vraiment de
raison d'exister
d'ailleurs on a même eu aussi droit à
des street fighter en 8 bits mais bon ça
non plus finalement je vous en parlais
pas parce que bon je veux dire par
exemple il existe un street fighter sur
master system qui est nul mais bon
pourquoi c'est nul je sais pas regarder
quelqu'un jouer à street fighter 2 est
maintenant sur master system
[Musique]
je sais pas vous devinez non un avis si
on fait sortir flight simulator 8 sur
atari 2600 il ya des chances que ce soit
de la merde aussi les mecs je comprends
pas je connais même pas les touches mais
c'est nul les combats ce trop court on
peut même pas profiter du jeu et bien
attendez j'ai mieux pour vous et oui les
jeux comme street fighter avec des
combats qui durent trois secondes c'est
un peu nul j'avoue mais c'est pas mieux
quand ça dure dix minutes c'est parti
pour ce l'auteur sport qui a aussi connu
au japon sous le nom de fat man est fat
man c'est l'identité secrète de fou
swain thunders porte sur megadrive jeu
qui fait clairement partie du top 5 des
plus mauvais jeu de combat de l'histoire
est déjà rien que l'intro et que du bon
goût bref après un rapide écran où on
vous demande de choisir entre un player
ou de player et bien donc je commençais
directes dans le jeu sans choisir deux
personnes avec en plus le personnage je
crois le moins charismatique du jeu
parce que bon je veux dire le short
décathlon et la moustache de portugais
non non j'affirme que si j'avais pu
choisir mon perso j'aurais pas commencer
par lui enfin je veux dire sans aller
jusqu'à des mecs qui ont des looks
improbables dans les tekken ou à des
héroïnes qui ont des espèces de pastèque
en bonnet g comprenant les dead or alive
mais ça serait bien d'avoir un truc
mieux parce que là c'est complètement
ton voisin en short
fayez salha je sais même pas si cette
attaque de flamme sert à quelque chose
que je veux dire visiblement en face le
mec ne réagit pas du tout quand je le
touche et est ce que je le touche au
moins je veux dire est ce que est ce que
je le touche dans ce jour on ressent
mais absolument pas les impacts bon je
veux dire ça semble basique comme truc
pourtant
reculer quand on se fait toucher ou
d'avoir une petite animation que
signifie qu'on a pris un coup mais même
les trucs basiques ce jeu ne les fait
pas en fait quelque part ce jeu il est
bien parce qu'ils te rappelle que tout
ce que tu prend pour acquis ou pour
évident dans un jeu de combat et ben ça
l'est pas en fait il a fallu que des
gens réfléchissent dessus tenez un truc
tout con quand l'ennemi passe derrière
moi mon personnage ne se retourne pas
automatiquement il lui tourne le dos et
c'est insupportable tourne toi tour de
toi [ __ ] je suis obligé de lâcher tous
les boutons de la manette pour me
retourner
sinon ils enchaînent les attaques du
mauvais côté je me fais défoncer par me
parle mon clown vendeurs de kebabs sur
namek la ligue ou bien que ce que vous
voyez là c'est pas n'importe quoi c'est
le jeu on combat c'est vraiment comme ça
avec deux abrutis qui sont partout et si
tu n'aimes pas ce personnage est bien là
aussi comme pour ses fans
1 tu vas pouvoir à l'état sort sur un
cactus mon petit roux de nous un parce
qu'ils accueillent persos jouables en
mode 1 joueur et c'est celui-là en même
temps de toute façon je suis pas sûr que
vous ayez vraiment envie de jouer les
autres persos à ce jeu il a vraiment les
coups spéciaux les moins impressionnant
du monde déjà le perso principal c'est
la tacc lance flammes
mais attention et c'est pas le lancer
non c'est le stade
voilà c'est le truc que tu bois les
samedis soirs sur la place de la gare
tous et un côté des mecs qui font du
djembé et ceux qui jouent du diabolo
après ça en mode 2 joueurs il ya le truc
qui ressemble à bourthes oh le gros avec
une langue dans le ventre il ya le
dragon qui pète et pète il ya le gros
qui se transforme en boule et il ya le
robot poulet qui lance du feu par son
cul par son cul bon enfin bref après
chaque combat vous pourrez apprécier les
subtilités du mode solo et par exemple
belle et barre de vie qui remonte pas
entre chaque faillite oui parce que fat
man c'est aussi un jeu de stratégie vous
devez racheter de la vie entre chaque
combat
comme vous pouvez aussi acheter des
items qui peuvent être lancés pendant le
combat du genre des items qui mobilise
cette empêche de sauter original c'est
vrai quelque part mais sérieux aux fêtes
bad c'est déjà un jeu qui est super dur
alors pourquoi vous essayer de rajouter
être chiant par dessus un truc nul qui
il me dit kaka sur son vomi mais
évidemment tout ça n'est pas important
l'important dans un jeu de combat c'est
le mode de player et c'est une [ __ ] de
grosses déjà premier truc
est-ce que vous repérez le problème la
mère père et vous le léger souci de ce
jeu en mode 2 joueurs dans ce que vous
voyez là hein
attendez je vous ai des idées ou le
deuxième joueur et il est où il est où
les enfants à regarder il est elle en
train de péter les caméras ne suis que
le joueur ça rend un peu certains
combats à vivre juste comme des
expériences absolument abominable vu que
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure les
personnages se rebondissent dessus comme
de ballons de plage et pour peu que tu
rajoute le fait qu'un des deux joueurs
va forcément avoir l'idée de génie de
prendre un perso super chiant du genre
le dragon qui volent tout le temps ma
droite ou par la chambre et qu'est ce ça
rend le jeu mais complètement
insupportable quand tu gagnes c'est du
hasard pur et simple et on s'est battus
tomberont est mon poulet la plume est
plus forte que le pet et le dernier
point dont j'ai pas parlé
les combats sont longs mais l'on sait
long en crever à vous vous amuserez plus
dans une file d'attenté la poste
sincèrement c'est une torture les coûts
ne font presque rien
et vu que dans ce jeu on est beaucoup
trop mobile on passe mon temps à sauter
et donc à s'esquiver [ __ ] c'est fou
c'est juste fou ce jeu c'est genre une
super attaque des chevaliers du zodiaque
vous savez
je vais t'en le vt cinq sens
d'abord mes horrible graphisme formeront
la plus maintenant je vais être en vie
louis écoute cette musique de l'enfer
vous pourrez chercher ce que tu veux sur
le net même les bruits les plus
horribles de l'humanité seront pires que
ce sont là le toucher tu ne comprendra
jamais les contrôles de ce jeu même au
bout de plusieurs années
la tendinite ep tendra les bras au fait
rigoler
[Musique]
goût oui parce que ce jeu est vraiment
cool merde au haillan que l'odorat mais
finalement on n'est pas loin de la
définition de l'enfer l'enfer ça doit
être juste être ça c'est finalement
c'est de jouer à fat man avec mon équipe
est à côté mais ce nul on s'ennuie je
fais du sang écoute je dois vraiment je
n'arrive pas à retrouver mortal kombat
mais j'en ai retenu va l'aimer parce que
c'est pareil
et oui c'est pareil mentale combas a
clairement été un des jeux les plus
cloné du monde je veux dire c'était
facile
le succès de mortal kombat sa reposer
sur une chose la violence vient mentale
combat ce n'est pas spécialement un jeu
qui réputé pour la qualité de son
gameplay
et puis en plus c'était un genre de jeu
relativement facile à produire n'y a pas
de faire saut à nîmes et il faut juste
des acteurs et prendre quelques photos
des clones de mortal kombat il y en a eu
didier chier dont celui d'à kasumi ninja
sortie sur jaguar en 94
j'aime beaucoup la musique de lancement
de la jaguar et quand tu sais que la
console est tout n'est-ce donc presque
un effet comique
nous on essaye de faire des jeux bon
bref donc kasumi ninja déjà le lancement
de jeu à temps mais l'écart déjà
visiblement les voies ont été faits par
michel leeb effectivement non attends
sérieusement chanac
[Musique]
à tintin est maintenant la carte mère
d'en acheter un
franchement c'est honteux on ne se
permettrait jamais nous de faire des
clichés comme ça dans nos émissions
[Musique]
quoi qu'est ce qu'il ya pourquoi tu me
regardent comme ça n était pas en train
de penser à faire un montage musical de
toutes les blagues racistes qu'on a fait
sur une musique du seigneur des anneaux
j'espère n'inquiète ouais donc on
commence d'abord le jeu par une histoire
qui défilent et qui dure environ cinq
minutes à [ __ ] sérieux c'est un jeu de
baston à on s'en fout c'est comme si on
te mettais une scène cinématique de 15
minutes avant un jeu genre pong
bon bref alors déjà le premier truc
hallucinant c'est que ce jeu possède le
pire système de sélection des persos du
monde
le pire vraiment si je vous dis écran de
sélection des persos dans votre tête
normalement vous voyez un truc comme ça
mais non un kasumi ninja la sélection
des perso c'est ça ouais super nom est
comme ça maintenant vous allez mettre
trente secondes à faire un truc avant
vous faisiez en 3 secondes
il en faut plus des jeux comme ça ça
c'est de la bonne idée il faut l'adapter
dans notre style de jeu
bienvenue dans gran turismo son fils
avant de commencer le jeu
veuillez chercher vos clés trouver les
quais ne vous ne pourrez pas jouer
trouvez les allez mots clés et l'eau et
c'est complètement con et ça parce que
tu déguise un menu que ça va devenir
autre chose qu'un menu là je pense que
s'ils ont fait ça c'est juste pour dire
nous sur la jaguar on a des grosses
couilles
on fait de la 3d concernant le jeu
vraiment je trouve ça un peu triste en
fait parce qu'entre les déluges de
mauvais goût du genre l'écossé qui tire
des boules de feu avec son boubou les
acteurs sont vraiment pato et te donne
pas du tout envie de jouer avec eux ils
sont pas gilles du tout en plus enfin là
je veux dire tu vois tellement qu'ils
sont couchés par terre pour faire les
animations que ce fonds pourrait tirer
un trait en dessous pour le sol si on
pouvez zoomer dans leur visage vraiment
je pense qu'on y verrait toute la
détresse de la personne qui fait des
choses qu'elle n'a pas envie de faire
pour nourrir sa famille typiquement
prenez l'indien ce pauvre mais qui n'a
rien d'un combattant il a juste l'air de
boire de l'alcool et d'avoir des parts
dans un casino et puis pourquoi est-ce
que la barre de vie issues du sang
c'est moche c'est absolument dégueulasse
et de jeu comme ça il y en a à la pelle
vraiment je pourrais par exemple vous
parlez de shadow war of succession sur
trois des eaux
ou alors je pourrais vous parler de
tatous assassins c'est un jeu qui n'est
jamais sorti mais qui a été fait par des
mecs qui se sont dit waouh les fatalités
de mortal kombat c'est trop bien alors
plutôt que de mettre juste une vingtaine
pour faire mieux que mortal kombat on va
en mettre 2196 et là vous vous dites
comment on peut avoir autant de fatalité
différentes
c'est simple en faisant n'importe quoi
[Musique]
voir qu'est-ce que
fait rare le mec qui a fait ça il a
juste balayé son regard dans la pièce où
il était et il a pris tous les objets
qu'il a vu pour en faire des fatalités
nous le sens est bien là mais moi je
veux des femmes aussi
ok attend un truc qui ressemble à mortal
kombat avec des femmes j'ai ça c'est bon
attention les prochaines minutes
contiennent des femmes en petite tenue
voici donc 10 secondes de moins en
mangeant une compote de pommes pour
laisser le temps aux jeunes enfants et
aux féministes de quitter la vidéo
[Musique]
vous êtes toujours là bon ben tant pis
on y va c'est quoi ça bornot ton truc
mais non ce bikini karaté bays ces
femmes en bikini qui font du karaté ah
ouais moi j'aurais appelé ça salon de
l'auto le jeu vidéo
choose your shoes duo ait un bon pour
ton jeu faut aimer la musique de tuning
bon je prends frau dit
puis toi tu prends athéna ok je me
demande comment ils ont fait pour faire
la plus deux jours vous aimez la musique
de tuning
vous aimez les nichons vous aimez la
mythologie grecque alors bikini karaté b
effet fort où il faut se dire que c'est
un jeu de niche de niche pardon de niche
qui suis fait jeter potes je peux pas
m'en empêcher
oui il ya même mode spectacle vous
n'avez même pas besoin de jouer vous
pouvez juste regarder ça aucun sens un
jeu vidéo que l'on veut pas jouer c'est
complètement inutile
[Musique]
bah quoi je m'en vais et il pleut dehors
ouais moi j'aime bien les meufs mais
est-ce que je quitte vraiment c'est les
tractopelles
[Musique]
ok la tam tam bien les tractopelles mais
j'ai ce qu'il faut et inquiète pas mais
pendant ce jeu ont poussé des furies dia
d'une barre aussi carré non
attendez il ya un chien qui conduit un
tractopelle c'est normal aux armes et
tekken bon mais se fait tort moi je me
rends très léger 17 heures il est
[Musique]
finalement que ce soit avec des femmes
en bikini des tractopelles des mecs mal
déguisée ou des combattants qui ont 12
fémur dans leur corps
l'important d'un jeu de combat c'est pas
son univers c'est qu'il ait une bonne
réalisation
je veux dire fait des jeux de baston
avec n'importe quoi des rappeurs des
grands mères des poissons on s'en fout
tant que c'est bien fait mais surtout
n'oubliez pas l'important c'est de bien
choisir son personnage pour finir le jeu
[Musique]
m